hey guys Pete here again for the second
half of the mr. robot season two
premiere this video has been broken up
into two parts because of the way that
they leaked the first half a few days
earlier but in the future they'll both
be you know I mean it won't be in two
parts anymore the reviews when people
open up it's actually you know kind of
good because there's a lot of stuff that
happened and it was a long episode so if
you haven't seen the part one video I'll
put a link up at the top and so you can
watch that one first second half of the
episode picks up a little later in the
day with CTO Scott Knowles rolling into
the park with two giant duffel bags full
of cash he waits for a while for our
society to make contact until a bike
messenger shows up he has him to sign
and gives him a backpack Knowles
gingerly looks inside to find a mass
with a note telling him to put it on and
burn the money he actually does as he's
told and you know when I first watched
it I was thinking it was pretty dumb to
have him do this but later when I
thought about it it was actually a
pretty good plan let's not forget that a
Corp is in a bad spot with his customer
since they can't access any other
databases so people who you know for
people to see this very public display
of destroying close to six million
dollars in cash I mean it's actually 5.9
million for the five nine hack but you
know that's a pretty good picture to
paint at the end of the day for F
Society it reinforces the disconnect
between those at the top and the average
person struggling in the wake of the
hack we see Darlene lurking in the crowd
and then we see you know before we cut
away to the next scene here we see CEO
Phillip price in a meeting with three
members of the Fed as far as I can tell
they explain that they have you know
they put out as much money as they
possibly could for e Corp and ask price
that to resign I have to say that you
know Michael Christopher the actor who
plays price is one of my favorites on
the show instead of agreeing to step
down he bet he turns things back around
and gives a great speech about the
nature of a con he walks out letting me
know that he better get what he wants
and it pretty much seems like he wants a
government bailout if I resign
than any scrap of confidence the public
is already clinging on to will be
destroyed
and we all do a calm
doesn't work without the confidence
we get a quick scene with Joanna while
look tied to a bed getting roughed up by
a character that we haven't seen before
he appears to be lukewarm in his
enthusiasm for indulging her kink and
the next scene another new character
emerges in a bodega having a
conversation with a cashier at a counter
that is like totally Easter Egg rigged
Dom de perro is the name of the the new
FBI agent and she's played by Meryl
Streep's daughter Grace Gummer who you
might know from the HBO series in
newsroom she's pounding a 5-hour energy
drink in buying more for the road and
surprises us by making you know speaking
to the Persian man behind the counter
and it's native tongue we don't have a
lot of info here it's a good setup for a
character and we get an idea that she
isn't a typical square like federal
agent title back in the field office we
see her deep in thought 'she prepares to
go sit down and interview gideon he
looks completely terrified but we don't
get to hear any of the conversation at
the basketball court we get an insight
into what Elliot has on his mind when
you look closely at the seams between
order and chaos do you see the same
things I see strain the tears the
glimpses of truth hidden underneath why
did they fight so desperately to mask
what they are
or is it that they become who they are
when they get on the mask sometimes I
wonder what you hide behind my silent
friend
what mask do you wear or are you just as
afraid as the rest of them mean am i a
friend nah man I'm different from there
we get a standoff between Leon and one
of the basketball players over the way
that the player like talks at him
another character ray steps in to break
up situation he's a new character as he
sits down Leon leaves and we notice
another person behind him and the
bleachers took takes off as well ray
knows who Elliot is which seems
suspicious and when he brings up
computers Elliot quickly shuts him off
mr. robot chimes in telling him that he
ought to hear him out but Elliot decides
not to engage we go back to joy in his
room and catch a catch a news opinion
piece of features Tyrell her lover
quickly changes the channel after
watching a bit of it and then we get an
awkward exchange with the Ecore security
detail coming in to help her out of the
bathtub we get reminded from the TV that
not only does all the evidence in the
five nine hack lead to Tyrell but that
he is also the top suspect in the Sharon
Knowles murder
Eddie cork we overhear Angeles coworker
talking about how she doesn't like her
and that the boss doesn't like her
either we see her sitting at her cubicle
and she's got these bits of cheesy
motivational decorations which are kinda
out of place we see Angela in action
negotiating on the phone with a TV news
producer and she seems actually really
capable she appears to be thriving in
this new corporate role and gets to shut
down the co-worker and her boss by
getting her way in the negotiation I'm
not really a big fan of the new Angela
in theory but I give her some bonus
points for listening to sonic youth of
what waiting for the callback Angela
storyline is difficult to sort out we
have an exchange at a bar with the lead
attorney in the lawsuit against her new
employer she refuses to leave the job
the lawyer tells her story that
basically boils down to Angela becoming
a corporate [ __ ] and you know it's a
it's a it's kind of a funny story but
it's also a pretty good dialogue of
where she's gone since last season we
then see this guy that she doesn't know
sit down next to her he asked her if
she's alone
we cut right to a scene of them in bed
in her apartment where it looks like
they just had sex while he's sleeping
she slips away and turns on a sort of
positive affirmations or
cognitive-behavioral kind of self-help
video this I guess is the the way you
know to see where she's at
she's trying to believe that she can
move into a role similar to that of
Phillip price and you know one that
commands just a blot of power in between
the two Angela scenes we got a shot of
Johanna at home discovering a package
left on her doorstep when she takes it
inside and opens it she finds a music
box with a cell phone taped to the
bottom we can only imagine the Tyrells
sent the gift and that the phone is from
him back at the basketball court Leon is
absent but Ray and his dog Maxine stop
by Elliot tries to lightly ask him to
leave which confuses him it turns out
mr. robot met up with him the night
before and Elliot doesn't have any
memory of it I really like the bit that
he says about the fake laugh and you
know points out the just how how did
these two what are these two doing
together I mean like it's it's it's kind
of a weird combo and you know Elliot
obviously freaks out that he doesn't
remember didn't remember meeting him and
he goes home and we get this awesome
exchange this morning I was sleeping
can account for a gap in my
consciousness and sometimes what do they
see and this is why I'm different
sometimes my mask takes over why did you
talk to him because I'm gonna make you
realize what
what will you make me realize
but they say me
for me this is really what makes this
show better than most the internal
conflict of who we are and who we try to
show others the fact that Eliot's mass
takes over and how he fights to
reconcile those two sides is the
underlying current in this season and
season one he had a battle he was in
this battle for with his loneliness you
know and that led to mr. robot coming
into the picture and ultimately the
events of the 5/9 hat in the midst of
all the fallout and consequences of that
he can't really even move beyond his own
mind the scene in his in his bedroom
ends with this which you just have to
watch again because there's really no
words like they're just
I'm late for my church piece so Elliott
wins for now and mr. robot is left to
reevaluate after that we get the real
twist of this half of the episode that I
don't think really anyone saw coming
getting this approached at a bar or
where he is having a drink by this
mysterious character who seems to know a
lot about him
the guy seems personal but there's an
undercurrent of a sort of creepy
conspiracy theorist
he tells Gideon that he knows who he is
and he thinks he is probably just a
patsy he uses an interesting choice of
language when he calls Gideon a crisis
actor and he says he's the perfect
vessel for their lies he's calling
creepy and in the end thanks getting in
before shooting him and saying it was
done for our country we see Gideon on
the floor dead or dying I can't help but
think that this is a positive for Elliot
in the sense that it takes off the heat
I mean he was a threat but at the same
time it cuts off any chance or any real
hope for him to redeem himself by making
things right I mean if you remember the
first season you know he mentions he
hacked Gideon and found nothing he said
he found that Gideon was a good man and
he doesn't say that about anyone else
and here we go getting it is now gone
and that's that we see Joanna at home
again looking at the music box she has a
baby monitor and the tyro phone on the
counter in front of her she hears the
baby cry so she gets up and it turns out
to be the exact right time to miss a
call it's an unknown number there's no
way for her to call back and you know
just it just is what it is the closing
scene is Elliott at his church group
nodding off well it sounds like they're
reading something from the Book of
Revelations he's likely tired from
staying up the night before doing mr.
robot stuff and this is all underscored
by the you know what they're saying and
talking about the Alpha and Omega the
beginning and the father and the son and
you know it ties together in a pretty /
way as he drifts off we go back to his
mom house and we see him on the phone he
once he hears it stopped ringing he says
hello and eventually we hear Tyrells
voice say bon soir Elliot
who is this there's almost too much
stuff to talk about in this two-part
episode there are a ton of Easter eggs
and hidden content they went over a
bunch of them on the after show last
night
not sure if you scan the QR code but
there are a few versions of that you
know different fans have uploaded you
can find online the title from his
campaign there's a little composition
book his notebook is the red wheelbarrow
so I don't know if you looked it up that
or not but it leads to this poem and
this is it in its entirety so that's a
little interesting I think it was a
solid way to start the season and even
though it posed more questions than it
answered I think it did a pretty good
job of moving the story long the
storyline along at the same time Eliot's
story and personal struggle really
overshadows the rest of the characters
for me but you know there's there's a
web in place and it should be pretty
interesting to see it all unravel I'm
wondering if there are ten more episodes
left or eleven I know they extended it
to twelve this season but I'm not sure
if part 1 & 2 count individually or as
one you know I mean I'm not sure how the
total all those work there's still a
couple big cliffhangers from the first
season we haven't seen anything about
yet most inevitably would be the knock
at Elliott's door at the end of season 1
and then that little meeting between CEO
price and White Rose in disguise in that
post-credit scene so there's like a lot
of stuff to think about a lot of cool
theories popping up as well one thing
that is picking up a following on reddit
is this idea that Elliott is actually in
prison or an institution so say that you
know that knock on the door was the
police and they came and locked him up
you know I personally don't think this
is the case because I think that it
works kind of how it is like he's in
prison in his own mind you know the the
the things in his surroundings do
reflect like a prison routine and I can
see how people are drawn to parallel but
I think it's largely about like a result
of his perspective you know he's cut off
from everyone and he hasn't been on line
what
you know weird something that he was
always doing and at the same time he
can't trust himself for his
decision-making beyond the scope of this
routine he set up for himself so it
could be true you know that that would
be an awesome twist but I don't know let
me know what you think about that and
let me know if you have any other ideas
or theories in the comments you know I
definitely like reading them and I'll
try to respond as best I can
please like the video and subscribe
we'll be doing I'll be doing it reviews
at least throughout the season and
possibly like some trailer breakdowns or
Q&A s if there's lots of questions and I
have time thanks for watching I'll talk
to you soon